derrière ces cintres jean michel masson
habitants de trappes et et
manutentionnaire dans la zone
industrielle il est actuellement en
recherche d'emploi et fait partie des
six personnes qui sont accompagnés par
la cravate solidaire mobile le but de la
cravate solidaire et de lutter contre
les discriminations liées à l'apparence
en entretien d'embauché
le but principal c'est de revaloriser
aussi l estime de soi des personnes en
insertion professionnelle
jean-michel explique son projet
professionnel aux bénévoles avant son
coaching en images dans ce camion
aménagé en dressing ci sera peut-être
bien c'est que vous trouvez une chemise
et veste ses records la mission de la
coach en image trouver la tenue idéale
pour jean-michel il faut pas mettre de
type la coach en image doit tenir compte
des goûts vestimentaires de jean-michel
mais aussi du poste visé chemise veste
chaussures jean-michel pourra garder
cette tenue professionnelle complète
grâce aux dons perçus par la cravate
solidaire mais dressing de la cravate
solidaire est composé à la fois de
deudon qui nous viennent de particuliers
de collaborateurs d'entreprises est
également de marque de textile
métamorphosé jean michel est ensuite
plongé en situation réelle d'un
entretien d'embauché genre recherche
d'emploi il efface un binôme de
responsables en ressources humaines qui
lui donne les clés pour se mettre en
valeur et renvoyer une bonne image lors
de ces futurs entretiens
pour l'instant je reste flou sur ce que
j'ai déjà pour voir si ça me confirme
nos ports c'est sa maman bas pendant la
chasse à la fin de l'atelier jean michel
repart avec une photo pour son cv ou les
réseaux sociaux professionnels et
surtout un regain de confiance en lui